the Afra mentioned Jeff Passan did a
great job following the Mike Trout story
and guess the Angels and trout
finalizing a 12-year four hundred and
thirty million dollar extension why now
Jeff I think damn that Mike Trout wanted
security for the rest of his life and
wanted to know where he was going to be
and look he's in the forty four and a
half million dollar deal right now so
clearly he's got that security
financially but I think he wanted
baseball security as well and the
relationship between him and the Los
Angeles Angels is as strong as any in
baseball and as much as the Phillies
dreamed of him coming home and being the
kid who grew up rooting for the team and
playing at it's uniform it was just a
longshot to happen and Marty Marino
steps up with the the biggest contract
in sports history by a longshot
if Bryce Harper didn't openly flirt with
Mike Trent like did anything and trigger
let's get this done before the start of
the season no interestingly enough I
don't think there was a ton of momentum
on this deal until recently because Mike
Trout you know he had designs on five
hundred million dollars and you can make
the argument that five hundred million
dollars would have been worth it for him
because we're talking about a guy who
may ultimately go down if he continues
on the same path he's he's been on for
the first you know eight years of his
career is the best player in baseball
history and I know that's you know it's
recency bias it's prisoner of the moment
but the fact is the numbers back that up
this is a historically good player and
the Angels simply did not want to lose
him and so here we are 430 plus million
dollars later can you make an argument
it's a good deal for the Angels
financially I think you can make yeah I
think you can make a really good
argument that it's a good deal for the
Angels I mean if Zack Greinke who
previously held the average annual value
record at thirty-four point four million
dollars is just a million and a half
dollars cheaper a year than Mike
Mike Trout is you know as good as that
cranky is no disrespect intended my
trout is Mike Trout we're talking about
the best in the game and and you know as
good as Mookie Betts is as good as
Francisco Lindor is as good as some
others may ultimately be Mike Trout is
the guy in baseball and he's being paid
like the guy but not to the 40 million
plus a year level that I think a lot of
people thought he was gonna get who's
who's next uh you know that's a great
question I know the Indians would love
to get Lindor locked up I don't know if
that's gonna happen Mookie Betts is
clearly another guy who the Boston Red
Sox adore they love him as a baseball
player they love him as a person and
they would love to get a deal done with
him as well
I could see either of those guys being
in the 300 plus million dollar range but
now it seems like 400 is going to be the
new number and and 400 is a big big one
Wow yeah I'm wondering about Aaron judge
I I get the feeling Aaron judge might go
quietly like Mike Trout with a contract
extension I don't know if Mookie Betts
will be quiet but you know the agent
plays such a large role in this can you
see something like that extension with
Aaron judge that you know that's what
the Yankees would do I think the Yankees
would love to extend our and judge
because again look at the players that
we're talking about here Mookie Betts is
beloved as a person Francisco Lindor is
beloved as a person Aaron judge you know
I remember and Aaron judges rookie
season the Yankees came to Kansas City
where I live and Matt Holliday is a guy
I've known for a long time and whom I
deeply respect and Matt Holliday
came up to me and said unprompted Aaron
judge is my favorite young player that I
have ever seen and and the
the amount of love that he has
throughout the Yankees organization and
the amount of respect that he's
engendered in issue you know what tell
tell Jeff Thank You Todd I know he's
busy but he made some time just to
update us on this for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]